people keep asking how much RAM should I
buy for my new Mac and in 2023 it is
actually tougher and more important to
get it right than ever before now we
have made a ton of videos on this topic
doing tons of different tests but they
cover one specific Mac with two
different amounts of ram so in this
video I'm gonna make the simplest
easiest to follow video to know exactly
how much you need so you know under buy
and have an underperforming mac and you
don't waste a ton of money which is very
easy to do especially for the 16 inch we
can spend up to a thousand two hundred
dollars more just upgrading your RAM
starting out with the M1 MacBook Air
which you can buy for 800 bucks right
now on Amazon we'll have all the links
down below I would say that if you're
buying this machine just buy the base
model one thing has to do with the
really fast ssds at the base that act as
RAM when is using swap to write to it
and all that really matters is that if
you want a great budget machine just
pick it up and enjoy it and if you're
considering upgrading Ram you should be
buying the M2 MacBook Air or the M2
MacBook Pro which perform the same in
terms of ram these systems along with
the M2 Mac Mini all come with eight gigs
of RAM standard which to be honest I
think should not be happening in 2023
now if you do simple usage for example
web browsing email using iMessage
through your Mac things like that this
is going to be just fine but for
everybody else out there that wants to
use your MacBook for productivity for
example photo editing video editing or
anything else we found that there are
major differences in performance for
example in blender 16 gigs of RAM was
drama dramatically faster than eight
gigs of RAM and the same thing for photo
editing the 16 gigagram was almost twice
as fast now if you remember back with
older Intel MacBooks you would spend
2-300 more to get 10 15 more performance
but when can you upgrade to 16 gigs and
get almost doubled that is crazy but
what's even crazier is that if you're
multitasking the whole system can slow
down a lot which you guys may have
noticed in the past things take seconds
longer sometimes four or five times
longer to load up and at times the M2
air can actually be slower than that 800
M1 MacBook here that I showed you now
that is because the ssds with the M2
chips are about half the speed and if
you don't have enough RAM it will write
that to the SSD so if you care about any
sort of productivity I would spend that
extra two hundred dollars it is money
well spent for the empty MacBook Air M2
MacBook Pro and the M2 Mac Mini now
before we move on to 24 32 64 and 96
gigs of RAM if you already bought a Mac
and it is slowing down you have 8 gigs
of RAM you need our sponsors really
useful app cleanmymac X that can help
clear up RAM and junk files it's
available on the App Store and was
featured there as one of the best apps
to tidy up your Mac I've used so many
Macs and this app is helpful on all of
them both old and new clean my Mac X can
delete files quickly and automatically
including hidden leftover junk files you
can also update apps scan and delete
malware clean up cache monitor health
and much much more their menu provides a
ton of useful info and if your Mac is
slow use the free up memory button with
one click I bought it three years ago
because it is super powerful while
having a simple app-like experience
including the assistant recommendations
and the awesome lens tool that helped me
find and delete a forgotten 55 gigabyte
backup use the link in the description
to try all of the features with a 7 day
free trial or buy it with our 25 off
discount Link in the description below
for the next two weeks now the M2 Max
also come with a 24 gigabyte option but
for most of you guys that need this
video I would not buy it because by the
time you add some extra storage and you
move up and click that you're spending
nineteen hundred dollars and for that
price you can buy a 14 inch MacBook Pro
uh for Less once it's discounted and the
only people that actually are benefited
by that 24 gigs and we made a dedicated
video on this is if you know you are
going to be running virtual machines but
once again at that point you would get
better performance if you upgrade One
Step Up Now Apple already plans out
their steps to make sense and get you to
spend more money but one positive is
that if you're gonna go with an M2 Pro
either a 14 inch MacBook Pro or maybe a
Mac Mini it automatically starts out
with 16 gigs of RAM and I have to say
this if you're buying a Bend M2 Pro in
either a 14 inch MacBook Pro or in a Mac
Mini that has a 10 core CPU 16 core GPU
it is not worth jumping up to 32 gigs of
RAM unless you fit into a couple
categories because the way these systems
work is that the ram can be a limitation
but if your CPU or your graphics is a
limitation first for a lot of compute
tasks then the ram won't really help so
for most people if you're gonna do that
you would want to upgrade to the 12 core
CPU 19 core GPU before you upgrade your
RAM and one issue with that is if you
want a great deal like for example 1900
bucks on Amazon the biggest discounts
are for those pre-configured models so
you end up spending even more now there
are a couple categories that might want
to upgrade 32 gig even with the base
processor and that is if you do music
production with a ton of plugins that
don't work well off of your SSD using
swap or you're running parallels we're
running Windows and Mac at the same time
or other virtual machines that is when
it's worth spending that money but most
of you guys out there that do that
already know this now another benefit
that comes in is video editing and I'm
not talking about simple projects if
you're somebody that's working with raw
footage or you're doing multi-camer you
have three four camera angles or
projects that are 30 minutes long an
hour long you have a lot of stuff open
that's when your system can bog down and
32 gigs will help now what about if
you're buying a 16 inch MacBook Pro and
you're buying the most expensive 3500 M2
Max option now that one with mt Max will
give you the ability to upgrade to 64
gigs of RAM and new this year you can
upgrade to 96 gigs of RAM which is a
1200 upgrade from 16 gig with the M2 Pro
I did a ton of testing and through
everything that I could from various
programs and the difference between 32
gigs and 64 is minuscule even running
virtual machines parallels Windows 11
with performance tasks on both systems
the 32 gig model handled everything we
threw at it so in that case who should
buy 64 gigs of RAM well some people have
a lot of extra money they want to Future
proof so they'll do that or some people
know that they're going to do something
very specific that's going to use an
insane amount of RAM and they don't want
to even worry about having issues and in
that case with 96 gigs of RAM for
another 400 who should spend that money
well if you're doing scientific research
that's based on Ram or you're running
full-on orchestras and Symphonies with
tons of plugins that need that Ram
something extremely specific maybe you
will need it now of course with the Mac
Pro you can get up to one and a half
terabytes of ram that's why they allow
that option for people that need it in
that case you know it but if you're
watching this video I would say that 32
gigs of RAM has been great that's what I
do for my machines and the whole 96 Giga
Ram or for example 24 gigs of RAM those
high-end extra options they are very
rarely worth it for almost anybody and
other than the base 8 gig of RAM with
the M2 Chip the rest of the lineup for
example 16 gigs with M2 Pro or 32 gigs
with M2 Max that is the sweet spot for
performance so simple rule don't get the
highest end and don't get the base 8 gig
and you are going to be great and spend
your money elsewhere so I hope that
simplified it for you guys if you have
any other questions ask it down in the
comment section below click that Circle
above to subscribe check out one of
those videos right over there this is
Max and I'll see you in the next one
foreign